das ist halt wirklich es hat so einen
gewissen mario kart charakter findet ab
durch die mitte
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde horse racing auf hat endlich
wieder online ist mein lieblings server
und wir
ich denke allerdings fest scheiße los
los los fährt ja ja das ist schon mal
gut ich stecke einfach schon wieder fest
spring spring klingt ja gut kommt wenn
du fertig bist mit dem rennen hier dann
also ihr könnt horse racing auf das rad
ein bisschen wild ist hier gerade aber
wir machen hier gerade horse racing und
es ist sowas von hektisch es ist
unglaublich
allerdings ich belege gerade den zweiten
platz glaube ich das sagt doch alles
immer noch so ein bisschen allerdings
weiter das liegt an dem pferd und nicht
an den server und zweifel games und so
was alles ist es ein mega nice es läuft
auf jeden fall richtig so weil wir games
sowie so kann der dann einfach über die
blätter da weitergehen
soja kommen stecken schön test ich bin
doch gar nicht drinnen auf fährten
locken jetzt dann wohl auf den jetzt
haben hier einfach drüber sagt habe ich
gut gemacht ich gut gemacht haben die
anderen stecken fest sagt jetzt hier
drüber ja ok geil geil geil geil geil
los weiter ok also ziel das ist einfach
ihr könnt euer fertige steuern und es
ist halt wie so ein rennen und ihr müsst
dann halt irgendwann ein ziel
es hat halt schon ein wenig allerdings
die ganzen anderen sachen so wie zum
beispiel ganz so läuft alles
spitzenspiels jetzt auch nur noch auf
heavyweight champion der beschreibung
gesagt dann darf ich auch direkte
ansprechpartner mit denen man reden kann
und bei heißt es einfach halten ist halt
so habe ich ja schon mal darüber geredet
was dabei half so ist jetzt mal hier
gibt es noch andere hinter uns nicht
sind nicht wir müssen auf jeden fall ein
bisschen her ist fragt er halt schon
heftig müssen
der dyson erst da ganz vorne und ich
frage mich ob wir durch hier warum
nein nein jetzt hab ich hier so lange
rum
weiter los los los los los los tierhof
schnell schnell schnell schnell schnell
das ist halt wirklich es hat so einen
gewissen mario kart charakter findet ab
durch die mitte
so ist das jetzt schon die feine weine
stage jedoch links vorm dann ihr recht
ihr könnt ihr uns auch weitere modi
irgendwie so die kommentare schreiben
bzw
einfach mal wenn ihr jetzt gerade noch
dran seid nachdem wir hier die ganzen
lexus schon gesehen habt schreibt mir
alle jolo in die kommentare jolo ich bin
immer noch da ich nur noch zu
so kann es hier weiter jetzt können wir
ganz jetzt hier gucken ist einer hinter
uns nie aber da kommt keiner den berg
und blöder fehler hier natürlich von
kontraste an den start gelegt da läuft
jetzt hier um die kurve es liegt
natürlich wie sars lag wie soll ich weiß
nicht ob es an den fernseher oder doch
im server ich weiß nur dass sowohl games
super geklappt ab 2 grad schon
aufgenommen allerdings sondern sofort
alle auf einen drauf gehen ist es auch
nicht so übel
ich frag mich hat der der s bahn begeben
das heißt wir müssten theoretisch wenn
du mal weiterlaufen würde es hier fährt
momentan bin ich bin ich im finish
gewesen wie sich der wievielte ich wurde
glaube ich das schon durchgewesen ich
weiß nicht aber ich war doch ganz weit
vorne eigentlich war doch zwei tage
glaube ich so naja wir hängt auch eine
runde karten kreis noch so ein bisschen
horse racing hinten dran und zwar auf
jetzt mal wieder dahin
also so sehr wie wir hier aufgebaut ich
laufe zum horse racing hin und zwar oft
ihre rhetorische basis da läuft einfach
hin oder her passe weil die dargelegt
sind also hier ich weiß nicht wie viele
matches gibt
ich glaube es gibt mehrere sogar ich
versuche es einfach mal besser
abzuschneiden so wer ist denn die weight
rating rating da oben in die 1 in watte
lautet warum ich jetzt hier hin müsste
eigentlich so ein paar nachkommen wir
wollten jetzt erst mal und zwar gibt es
nur eine map auf sport1 und wir sind die
einzigen gerade drin mit minecraft sie
minecraft sieht nicht nach weil zwei
race also horse trails auf jeden fall
ein mega geiler modi modus nicht nur die
feier ich auf jeden fall feiern us
freundin ist auf jeden fall geil so da
kommen ein paar andere hier der florian
nix minecraft sieht leisten sieht voting
red bull teams tatsächlich gamestar
erinnerte laut swisscom band auch mal
gut mein ziel es ist definitiv diesmal
vier leute ok den ersten platz zu machen
ganz klar also die schon gesagt wenn ihr
mehr davon wollt dann könnt ihr einfach
den daumen hoch geben
ich weiß jetzt auch grad gar nicht mehr
was ist das hier eigentlich los ist
was wenig unterfalle ahnung was da jetzt
ist ihm auch nicht so dort auf 30 74
leute 27 26 25 also wenn ich hatte ja
videos die ihn wie unter zehn minuten
lang sind es einfache weise nicht dass
ich so wenig ihr könnt mir übrigens auch
mods in die kommentare schreiben
ich will mal richtig viele kommentare
unter diesem video sehen weil ich will
mich hat anfechtbar damit geschäft im
ganzen kommentare durchzuforsten habe
ich dann nicht so was sehen die ja
schaut auf einem kanal vorbei sondern so
eher in die richtung ja hier der mode
ist der modus ist cool und hier der
model die mod ist auch geil die kannst
du mal vorstellen und so was alles
darauf hätte ich mehr bock so wir müssen
jetzt hier auf jeden fall da starte halt
direkt die mir drin geiler typ wie es
ist der formel sind genau zeitgleich
gestartet spring doch pure weiter geht's
nein nein ich stecke bändchen chance
darin kann man jetzt bin ich jedoch ganz
vorne oder so fasst zumindest und jetzt
komme ich nicht mehr durch junge scheiße
scheiße scheiße
keiner mehr hinter mir okay jetzt muss
ich aufholen ok ok schon wieder und noch
mal also die steuerung ist echt doof
wird man also sagen ich weiß dass durch
die lecks kommt sogar einfach so wir
müssen jetzt allerdings einfach mal
wieder den anschluss finden weil die
sind da alle unten am chillen und wir
kommen so elendig nach also ich springe
und zehn minuten später wird das also
meinem einer anfang anfänglicher
euphorie ist jetzt schon leicht wieder
gedämmt aber ich werde schon da hinten
wieder
ich muss jetzt nur hier irgendwie
durchkommen ohne dass hier so gut den
habe jetzt überholt so der nächste ist
jetzt auch völlig der förderverein jetzt
ausschließlich fahrer geradeaus und dann
sind die einfach mal so ein kaktus das
bei mir selbst auch nicht anders das war
das duo wenn man springt sondern springt
einfach gegenden kaktus man springt
einfach so gegen oder gegen sachen soll
in sanskrit wir game ja das heißt ich
habe jetzt auch heute viele sind drin 1
2 sind weg läuft lol lol
wo bin ich
wag wag ich bin unterm unter der erde
chillig wie soll ich denn jetzt hier
rauskommen alter junge das ist jetzt
nicht so geplant dass man hier hin
wieder rauskommen muss mit denen lex
junge scheiße alter die tonne die runde
kann ich doch direkt in die tonne
kloppen
fakt ist kann er nie sein alter ich ihr
die linde
ich will mich hier so rum back einfach
mal am boden fest management mensch egal
leute die aufholjagd beginnt und sie
wird wahrscheinlich das ganze ende noch
andauern weil das dauert jahre bis ich
immer durchgehend also wenn horse racing
besser läuft als echt geil
aber seit die schaut leider nicht der
fall hier lang wird schon läuft auf
jeden fall bei diesem spielmodus wohlauf
weiter läuft weiter du kleine [ __ ]
der jahre mehr raum herum haben der
neckar verlost
domian bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
vielleicht weil ich die ganze zeit in
diesem scheiss backware ich das auch
geschafft
sie werden sogar noch dritter geworden
oder der dritte hätte ich ihn gekriegt
locker easy modell vierter er bleibt
jetzt einfach aufstehen auch gut
loki spiel ist vorbei aber ach man also
es ist legt es hell verstehe ich nicht
vor allem weil alle anderen spielmodi
klappen super so kommen jetzt jetzt
komme ich auch mal irgendwann los sein
weiter fordert dort gemacht crafter gg
altstadt schnauze
da komme ich ja jungs wir sind letzter
lokal sei durch gepusht hören sind
wann er gut leute das war's mit horse
racing ich kann jetzt will das nicht so
ganz geklappt hat also ich bin gerade
auch am rennen an nebenbei für mega
projekt folgen da wo kämpfen bezogen
wird auf jeden fall sorry wenn ihr dann
auch mal die zweite runde beute dahin so
etwas könnte mir das gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
sonst halt auch mods und so was alles
können wir auch mal wieder in die
kommentare schreiben
andere spielmodi in minecraft und dann
will ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich
über einen mag ich freuen sondern sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder